what does it mean to be funny Well
everybody's funny I mean there's no um
there's no one way to be funny or one
definition of funding I think that uh
there's a difference between funny and
comic uh is is one of the things that we
talk about
you know in my first book The Hidden
tools of Comedy we talk about the fact
that uh you know anytime anybody makes
somebody laugh they're funny but
um but comic is is kind of an art form
and it's the way of it's the art of
telling the truth and specifically it's
about telling the truth about human
beings so that when people are
I think when people are funny if we're
talking about in terms of uh of writers
um uh directors actors I think what
they're doing is they're they're seeing
what what we see from a specific angle
from a unique angle it's like somebody
once said that fish don't see the water
because it's all around them and so
comic fish
are they're going around into saying hey
you know it's all wet around here uh
have you noticed that uh you know you
notice the thing about water so that's
you know if there was a stand-up fish so
I think I think a comedian is somebody
who
is slightly
off-center to where the majority are but
what he says isn't off-center it's dead
center it it totally makes sense in
retrospect so when a comedian makes a
joke uh at for you know at first the
audience he takes the audience where
they don't know they're going to go but
when they get there they go oh
of course so it's it's both surprising
and inevitable the punchline of a joke
is surprising and inevitable so so if
you ask me uh what's funny or who's
funny I think
um I think we all have the capacity uh
to enjoy humor to to make jokes I mean
we we just had our Thanksgiving dinner
right and uh and and we were around the
table and people were making jokes and
then away from the table people were
ranking jokes about the people around
the table
so that so that we
we all have the capacity
to enjoy humor to create humor
but some of us have the capacity to see
the world in in a unique way and then
share that Vision in a way that is both
surprising and yet inevitable what is
the comedy perception test ah okay uh
when I first started doing workshops
um and trying to talk to people about
the difference between funny and comic
um what we uh what I did was I created
what I called the comedy perception test
and it was all variations on a man
slipping on a banana because a man
slipping on a banana is the uh is kind
of the The Ground Zero of of of of a
comic joke
um so it was just a man slipping on a
banana and man slipping on banana after
uh kicking a dog and man in Top Hat
slipping on banana and if I can remember
all the ones uh man slipping on a banana
after losing his job
um blind man slipping on a banana Blind
Man's dog slipping on a banana and
finally man slipping on a banana and
dying and I would these were the seven
um seven word word pictures and then I
would ask the people in the workshop
choose which one you think is the
funniest the least funniest the most
comic and the least comic and
somebody would invariably ask me well
what's the difference between funny and
comedy and I would
not answer them but I would just say
listen it's whatever you think
um maybe maybe they're all uh equally
funny maybe they're all equally not
funny just choose which one you think is
the funniest the least funniest the most
comic the least comic they could you the
two of them could be the same and so
then we start with well
um how many people thought a was the
funniest how many people thought B was
the funniest and after the end of that
you know we totaled them up and uh and
we'd say you're all right
because funny is subjective if you think
something's funny if you're laughing at
something
to you it's funny
um but how useful is that
in terms of creating narrative either as
a director or as a writer or as an actor
because if you're chasing funny by
definition you're chasing a fraction a
subset of the audience because some
people thought that man slipping on a
banana peel was the funniest some people
thought that man slipping on a banana
peeling dying was the funniest and and
those people you know thought the other
person was wrong so if you're creating a
script and you're trying to make it
funny
by definition
um you're excluding a portion of the
audience because I mean here let me see
if I if I can show you this oh great
um here uh I I have a niece uh she's now
a a teenager which is causing my brother
and sister-in-law no amount of pain uh
but when she was a little kid I would be
able to
shake my keys and make her laugh
I can make
Karen laugh too yeah look at the keys
look at the keys and and so the question
is
my niece is laughing Karen's laughing so
is this comedy I mean would you spend
six months of your life developing this
as a feature you're laughing
so so there's the thought is that
there's a difference between funny and
comic and comic as I said before is the
art of telling the truth about human
beings the art of telling the truth
about human beings because
basically what we're doing when we're
writing comedy is where
Illuminating exposing that which is
both
wonderful and ridiculous glorious and
absurd about what it's like to to be
here on this planet as us
um
and at this point somebody will say well
isn't that true about drama
and and my response to that is usually
yeah drama's great drama is great
nobody's saying that trauma isn't great
but drama helps us dream about what we
could be
wood that I were as eloquent and as good
looking and had as much hair as some of
those people you know in those traumatic
films and those action films
so drama helps us dream about what we
could be but comedy helps us live with
Who We Are
comedy helps us live with who we are and
it's it's not
incorrect to state that you can watch a
dramatic film
in which
there's really not a lot of humor not a
lot of intentional humor
um but you can't watch a comedy without
without
moments of pain loss regret
uh
failure
hurt so so for me and I guess I guess
because uh I teach comedy and comedy
writing and I've spent my whole life
doing that I've written two books about
that
um I'm prejudiced but to me comedy is
the art form that really gets at what
it's like to be human and uh and at the
same times make you laugh
so so it has that going forward too
you know one of your two books you have
can we just see the the cover there
because you have the banana peel which
how did that become synonymous with
comedy well I think
um
you know I I actually am not sure these
and there's somebody probably out there
uh in in the world of the internet uh
probably will tell me that uh give me
the exact uh time and date that somebody
slipped on a banana peel but I think it
really was
um this in the silent films when
um when you had a car you you had no
sound so it was all physical comedy so
you had somebody slipping on something
um and that was that was an easy joke uh
and so uh when we were trying to figure
out what would be a good cover for this
um there were all sorts of suggestions
and somebody said a gorilla playing
playing baseball and I thought
well I'm not sure if I I'm not sure if a
gorilla playing baseball is you're
really really defines what I'm talking
about so we we uh my brother who's
actually uh was in advertising actually
found this image for me and um and and
he sent it to me so uh so I I have my my
brother Michael to thank for the cover
um thank you which was yeah because it's
this beautiful lovely banana ready to be
stepped on right and for someone to fall
and for somebody to fall and and the
thing is is that
some people think that there's the
superiority theory of comedy in which
the theory is is that we like to look
down at people and we laugh at their
Misfortune
um Mel Brooks once said that uh uh
tragedy is if I uh get a paper cut uh
comedy is if you fall down a sewer and
die and that's that's a funny that's a
funny joke but I I I think that that's
really not how it works I think if you
don't like somebody or you really look
down on them
um
it's probably a a television show or a
movie that you that you you know if
you're streaming and you turn off
because you're not engaged my my take on
it is that
you're identifying with them that you
you know they're suffering the the
ignominy I think I hope I'm pronouncing
correctly that's a new one um uh that
that we that we hope we can avoid that
we hope that no one will find out about
right uh the time that we gave a big
speech in our fly was open
um so when the comic does that when the
comic actor does that uh you know we're
we're not ho ho ho that idiot
um
we're we're kind of going oh my God
there I was but you know and uh or or
you know thank God I wasn't there and I
think that
you're identifying with characters which
is why when uh
producers or Executives tell a writer to
make a character likeable they're
they're actually uh making an error
because it's not about making a
character likeable it's making them
identifiable making you empathetic to
that character even if that character is
a jerk like Ricky Gervais in the office
or like uh John Cleese in Faulty Towers
uh Danny DeVito and taxi we we don't you
know those characters are not likable
but we kind of understand them
maybe we've worked for somebody like
them maybe your dad was somebody like
them and the the power of Comedy
is that it's it's life-affirming
because ultimately the comic is
basically saying
you're okay it's okay so you slipped on
a banana peel so a pie hit you in the
face so you you were humiliated so you
were uh you failed at that and you you
screwed that up
you're still you'll live you're still
alive you'll be okay and if and if
you're not living then you have nothing
else to worry about so so the
comedy is ultimately uh the art of
hope
because it even though our characters
slip on a banana peel
um there's always the hope that they'll
get up and and something better will
happen and if you look at almost any
comic film
that's what happens our characters start
off as flawed uh individuals who are who
are usually blind to their own flaws and
over the course of two hours
they they they go through a
transformation
not that everything's going to be better
not that they're going to change not
that they're going to be super men or
super women but there's the hope
at the end of it
that the world is going to be better